selon vous quel chroniqueur devient le
plus laid ce qu lorsque franck à pied
toi le patron ne s'évitent passe à côté
de lui j'ai ma petite idée
alors vous voulez cas ça castagne
j'aurais dit casse toi pôv bernard
mathieu delormeau oui aussi c'est vrai
matthieu delormeau alors vous venez me
bat jean banshee bah oui oui vous tuez
les kasmas également qui a fait ça bon
c'est rien
si on plafonne aurait fait voir le
moment est très grave en fait voir et de
l'autre côté une excuse en
masse thomas pesquet en nombre
important
l'espace
l'infiniment petit à l'infiniment grand
modèle pour vous le super nes ou bien
sûr c'est une horreur chaque fonds
capitaux passe il lui dit tu as vu comme
j'ai ridiculiser castaldi avec mes
audiences s'est retrouvée hier quand
même un record hier il a bénéficié de
1er novembre
vous minimisez ma valeur mais alors que
j'ai comme bouc
elle a une peau du parler s'il vous
plaît non tu peux tu peux pas parler
comme ça au chef tu sais si c'est vrai
c'est ça
tu veux dire bernard montiel où je pense
que je vous met
ça va
contrat oui et signé des deux barges et
pas signer ma maison qui l'ont signé
abbas et je vais vous assigner conseil
prud'hommes j'ai
[Applaudissements]
fait moi des procès vous savez on verra
qui se fatiguera le premier qui
allait alors on vous a pas demandé
je suis tu vois je suis en clientèle je
vous rappelle que
je suis donc je finis importés
l'impressionner comme d'un homme et
d'une femme a perdu tous ses titres
mais vu comment ils n'en ont pas cru que
j'ai changé oui c'est vrai vous avez
raison je crois qu'à ce qu'est une
fronde contre bernard montiel ah oui
voilà l'histoire ils sont jaloux ils
sont jaloux j'aimerais bien savoir de
bois
avec qui autour de cette table vous ne
seriez pas serein si votre moitié se
retrouver enfermé dans un ascenseur
c'est alors ça c'est à moitié
du cast à cyril va bien sûr cyril
guyot
syriza tasta syrie
parce qu'il peut qu'il fallait
bernard way ah oui ah oui oui oui oui il
est très séducteur c'est vrai bien songé
mais qui cache son jeu là c'est pas
toujours
évident hier soir une équipe à la peine
et médicalisée du coup là il m'a dit
qu'il était amoureux de l'amour et du
fait du beau physique des django et
quand c'est beau et bat catastrophique
du coup il m'a dit il m'a dit que si je
décide à entrer dans ma vie voudrais
bien me le faire
la déjantée a
pas longtemps son papa
sélectionné c'est reggie mais dit elle
est tellement belle je sais pas j'aurais
aimé avoir un enfant avec ce que je lis
des gens sont pas des ballons qui
l'adorent bernard c'est vrai c'est voulu
elle adore bernard
parce qu'on adore déjà concédé à oui
j'adore les gens d'abord des gens
préfèrent désormais que j'adore isabelle
j'aurais pu faire un enfant mais quel
monde ils accouchent à la couche de mal
à des gens sont deux ans
l'enfant et direct retraite
[Applaudissements]
ils sont pas sympas arrêté l'enfant de
moi et isabelle morini bosc qui sans
vous faire hélène gaubert est une pipe
[Rires]
merci tu veux tu en
voilà
guillaume quand vous aimez casta oui
mais un ascenseur mais j'aurais peur
qu'ils soient est fixé par ses
flatulences en fait
ça
alors vous mais diminuer les ressources
après parce que maintenant que
maintenant ça suffit les la légende l'a
pas de désir rien il n'y a pas eu les
mêmes personnes pas de meuf rien du tout
sauf du film à temps mais justement il
est célibataire pour ça qu'il est au
renouveau voilà justement il a forcément
un goût de ce garçon il ya hélas un peu
acteur un castel les
différents tuerie on n'a pas de passé
ouais bon petit fils d'yves montand il
adore il adore ben non c'est vrai c'est
le plateau lundi le messie est le
théâtre ses deux passions le théâtre et
la bicyclette
merci en tout cas si vous êtes vous
abaissez bon allez merci on aura le
droit de vous même et vous insistez pas
beaucoup
vous avez pas de souligner en voulait
dire que
je peux dire quelqu'un à qui j'aurais
absolument pas confiance dans un
ascenseur avec ma compagne facto c'est
vous ah oui je vous le dis honnêtement
ça vous surprend oui ça me surprend mais
oui mais oui parce qu'elle vous kiffe
attend donc sa cause d'effets à seebach
warwi attendait laquelle se
trouvait alors je veux dire fatou est
magnifique ouais tu une très belle femme
d'accord mal maintenant j'ai des règles
claires c'est la face à l'époque mais je
vous dis pas les potes à
l'époque pas à l'époque mais les
chroniqueurs
et chroniqueur je n'ai aucun problème à
voler leur me faire au cas par cas c'est
mon savoir bon bah oui c'est vrai la
bien oui c'est vrai c'est un passif
on va parler de 7 à 15 ans au minimum 15
et le passé en fait il faut tout
j'assume complètement monsieur
marseillais y trouver l'homme d'affaires
non non c'est pas un peu non mais qu'est
ce qui se passe de tout bois est en
train de dire que je voulais voler votre
nom je n'ai pas jeté pas avec elle ce
qu'on vous avez partagé non non on va t
on jamais avec
mtv qu'il ait lutté depuis deux heures
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous dire et je vais vous le
dire il s'est rien passé on n'est pas
sortis en sorcière levier vous parlez de
qui là parce qu'il détecte et lexine il
est persuadé je le dis que son aide est
sorti avec mon image personnelle puisque
me l'a dit surtout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons tissé une histoire mais je
vous dit vous n'avez même pas encore
commencé l'émission à mes essais mais
elle me l'a dire moi aussi ouais vous la
connaissez oui
vous allez quand même très moche à l'eba
je veux dire mentir à deux personnes
j'adore c'est un bien sûr mais voilà
merci en tout cas à jour me de me mettre
toujours en avant je suis d'une histoire
l'émission qu'il n'existait même bien
sûr vous êtes resté neuf ans ex ans
claire des choses que vous avez repris
avec elle oui je suis actuellement
alors c'était bien
[Applaudissements]
pascal
mais si c'est parce que c'est vrai que
c'est une histoire pointe schilling vous
la nourrir mais bien sûr ça on s'adore
mais c'est pas toujours facile voilà
donc c'est compliqué donc on s'en rend
sors mon ski ton sur mon sort
je vais vous dire je l'adorent bbc donc
je sais oui
[Rires]
je la gamme d'objets au bout de dix ans
franchement je suis très heureux pour
vous cg ati ses joies
il suffit d'établir en roulement
sortez soit est naze
il est 19 heures 24 c'est le temps
qu'elle sort mais ça va
amener un truc là par chariot entre
non mais c'est vrai on n'a pas de
questions à
selon vous
seuls quelques chroniqueurs serait
capable de renier cyril contre un gros
chèque et de changer de chaîne dès le
1er janvier 2022
alors allez-y montiel bernard pinaud
bernard montiel tout
je vous mets de pompe le sud tout ça on
tienne moitié à oui la star en corée
l'aide alors il ya beaucoup de montiel
désormais bernard lavoie il a dit
lui-même quoi alors france 2 tout ça
c'est vraiment moi je me casse dire
je veux revenir mais franchement
n'attendez pas le 1er janvier
la proposition m'a rien proposé encore
voilà si on attend la proposition n'est
pas prêt on doit pas
vous la vue sur quelques chaînes bordel
sans télévision mais ne vote pas le
bordel
monsieur je les appelais m'ont jamais
rappelé
johnny depp et delphine l'eau elle m'a
dit justin manière est montiel venir
mais toi tu voudrais pas
gilson montiel non non mais ça y est
vous voulez vraiment les gens font ce
qu'elles n'ont pas dupe et si vous
voulez des noms c'est arrangé le coup
sans rigoler non mais moi aussi par
france 3 pour même
séquence à bail de 50 ans vous savez
qu'elle veut pas d'aidé ce qu'il faisait
au début de 50 ans hélas oui c'est ça
c'est jean pelland kelly si moi j'achète
d'argent ils ont honoré ou
casse-toi quiros est pas non plus d'un
an alors il ya quelqu'un il ya
aujourd'hui qui m'a dit je le dis aux
téléspectateurs qui m'a dit je trouve
que tu paye trop les chroniques non non
c'est ça qui me l'a déjà dit puisqu'on
balance tout donnez lui un autre
producteur a donné les mecs vous
connaissez pas fait de cachette de
toutes les chaînes
on va dire ça et je vous dis je pense
qu'il aura du changement
il faut savoir combien on était payé
vous mais vous savez savez croire mais
vous ne payez il l'a su parce qu'il est
à passer le week-end avec un chroniqueur
de leurs maux non il ya quelqu'un assis
les week-ends de vie
luc lemoine a dit qu'il avait vu une
chroniqueuse sortir d'un magasin qui
commence par chat qui finit par neil
elle était chez chanel
mais si montiel part est-ce que vous
allez vous battre pour le récupérer non
la bonne blague
merci portelois la seule chose que je me
demande c'est oublie mon ne meurt
pas mais c'est vrai la moitié bien sûr
un cc un grand animateur pour vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
poser des questions
animé quoi baver
les animaux et les gags les animaux les
gags et la famille en or le méthane ou
le soya qui abrite la tombe était un peu
sur cette rue jean
jaurès est également pas beaucoup en
2007 sur cette île à nancy
[Rires]
cette saison
ap racing et mille autres c'est pour
bientôt parce que j'avais une émission
le visa mais vous savez que sur 100
français oui à qui on demande quelle est
la question la plus difficile que vous
déposez y répondent quel est le métier
de bernard montiel
les gens vous aviez une émission où vous
avez commencé cette phrase ya 2 minutes
ou non dans l'émission que je présentais
qui était la une est à vous le saviez
pas je me rappellerai que j'ai reçu
françoise sagan raymond devos françois
périer des gens que les jeunes ne
connaissent pas et c'est dommage session
et enfin peut-être mais en tout cas
c'était formidable ont bien ri merci
c'était de très belles démission ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout vous avez la
femme et oui je vous le confirme
personne s'est fait dans cette émission
il ya la famille en or
je raconte ma vie
je vous dirais le meilleur tu justifies
pas
si canivez d'où venez vous dit hier
pouvait lui faire confiance maintenant
posez vous les bonnes questions sur
certains compléments bernard parce que
je sais moi des sentiments bien
conseillés sur moi aussi ont changé
il est propre et pour mémoire bernard
odier j'ai du mal
c'est un match où il ya la vérité tu
joues et qui revient dans sous le soleil
je te jure si franchement je te trouvais
super non tu devrais pas retourner de là
bas
les chéris un moment donné qui vous a le
plus déçu autour de la table
droite pour moi c'est mon pied
avant de partir oui monsieur yves jégo
et ses choix c'est ce que moi je sais
pas bah dis donc toi du coup assez bien
alors je sais pas alors
on tienne monter à bord et celle d'un
gars vous revenez très saint
gilles à quoi jean pascal
c'est mieux maintenant maintenant il est
plus sympa ouais c'est vrai il était
d'être un héros des menteurs mais il est
tellement il était dur avec moi s'il
s'est amélioré ma vie était dure avec
tout le monde et moi avec sa main
cette émission est vraiment l'émission
de divertissement
mammy mammy a aujourd'hui on peut se
libérer donc je me lâche et en prime et
albert yuma
[Rires]
je vous ai cherchés attendu tout l'été
j'étais désespéré parfois vous m'avez
vraiment lescure is et le coeur alors
cet été j'ai vu très peu de monde
q
vous avez games est quand même venu il
est venu à la source voilà mes sources
et la source mais c'est bien la science
vous auriez bien la pente vous auriez
pris un seau d'eau dryden
on va essayer de tourner votre adresse
on va tous débarqué là où il était en
fait toi et
[Applaudissements]
ta terre vers la
thaïlande pascal papé tu veux aller en
fait
avoir plusieurs critères guatemala
il faudra gros quai d'amarrage pourquoi
montiel babos que je trouvais beaucoup
plus intelligent rouge jusqu'à ce que je
rencontre vraiment
sympa cette émission gens me disent qu'à
chaque fois qu'on en soirée une pique
tous mes plans c'est insupportable à la
vue de tous il fait ses regards acérés
pour femmes c'est vrai qu'avec les
muffins à passer un nîmois sur une
règle c'est un immense combat non mais
c'est vrai qu'on vienne - la politique
de la terre brûlée ouais
ben montiel également oui parce qu'il a
dit qu'il voulait partir et oui vous
laissez nous en avons aussi pas beaucoup
d'action et après on a été bon vous
allez me tous ben il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui se fout de l'âge que je
suis supposé avoir donc ça me gonfle
alors je tiens à dire franchement il
avale était ça du tout bien aller
j'avais jamais s'en est mêlée jaune de
ouf ça ne se voit pas
isabelle se réguler quoi d'où leur nom
n'a pas du tout
sans maquillage isabelle parsy
[Applaudissements]
vous
savez que mon mari me préfère toujours
sans maquillage well as bien raison
dallas est vrai passé si cette finale et
donc c'est que la vie tu prends bien
mais je trouve que tu supportes bien
toutes les valeurs c'est la doyenne
vraiment c'est là c'est là c'est la plus
ancienne de l'émission jeunesse ouvre
pas les
vallées bonnes séquences c'est sympa non
c'est pas la plus ancienne si c'est moi
on est tous les deux le même âge as tu
envie taux d'émission
a pris le sens
pascal que vous arrivez à chanter une
chanson alors une
autre chanson c'est fou ça un ballon
mais je trouve cette émission
passionnante
[Applaudissements]
passez un bon moment c'est pas de quoi
vous parlez
à parler d'un album tout à l'heure
c'était intéressant mais alors tu cites
masi et qu'est ce que tu veux me dire tu
chantes lune alors je vais te sort et le
[Rires]
chargeant d'une chanson sur est mort
alors que je vais te dire et il faut
totalement qu'est ce que tu as un autre
talent on évoque quatre jours son pardon
que tu as d'autres talents cannes où je
ne sais même pas si j'en ai mais en tout
cas je à 6 j'adore la musique ajoute m
quinze jours ah c'est vrai voilà je suis
un petit peu de peinture pour mon
plaisir à y est pas très bien ah ouais
ouais j'ai vu ses toiles sont
magnifiques quel style est passé au cap
ferret avec plaisir elle sait qu'elle si
oui quel style on peut les acheter ah
oui très cher non c'est vrai
que les accès n'ai pas cette prétention
non je fais ça pour personne à
mombasa beau non je fais ça vraiment
pour propos pour me détendre voilà vous
avez métier de façon dans la vie il faut
dollars courants de
déterminer ma gueule pour vous détendre
vous intéresse moi ce que je voudrais
savoir qu'on continue sur l'histoire de
chansons allant vers un mois là on en a
rien dedans mais c'est un enfer non mais
si on n'est pas nice que moi j'avais
fait aussi c'est presque des mash up en
fait ouais c'est ça ouais c'est à dire
que les paroles on peut chanter des
chansons et des paroles d'une chanson
sur une autre mélodie c'est ça oui vas-y
avis pas témoin de chants sont
maintenant à tu veux dire quoi mais moi
n'importe quoi moi je ne sais pas j'en
suis à toi tu ne bat lucie avec mistral
gagnant
et m'asseoir sur un banc
cinq minutes avec toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette émission vraiment divertissant
venu présenter
plaisir